I enjoy them in movies like the Martian
American hustle ant-man and now you can
check them out on the Netflix's new
original series season 1 of narcos
mexico streaming this Friday Michael
Pena good to see you sir good to see you
bud
awesome welcome to this program man I've
really enjoyed your your work throughout
the years I don't need to have you here
so you alright as I could tell the way
you were rolling it on our Callaway
corner surface your golf guy huh yeah
I'm a huge golf guy and I you know I'm
used to like putting with a bettin Rd
putter you know I mean they're like face
balanced or whatnot
okay so you had a healer there I switch
to the mallet which was pretty nice
look at you yeah so you're a putter snob
is what you're saying no I mean well I
mean that's a huge part of the game man
like you can drive it really long but I
just you know I'm setting one of those
things up in my house hopefully are you
saying that you putt for dough Michael
Pena um I try to you do do Drive for
shell um I do not drive for show those I
mean I've played with Tony Finau and
that guy's just dude who drives it so
far no I mean fee now fee now for me
okay out of everybody that that plays
I've never seen what happened with him
in the par 3 and the Masters where he
holds out celebrates dislocates his
ankle yeah and then damn they're wearing
the jacket anyway yeah exactly that's
unbelievable 10th place off one foot but
I you know I went to you togs I'm
friends with a bunch of those guys in
Utah and I imitated the the ankle break
a little bit how does one imitate an
ankle break well I basically I you know
I'd loosen my shoes and then I you know
I was pretending to you know cuz he has
a really short swing and then just went
but yeah I mean as he have a sense of
humor about it is it's not too soon
great sense of humor they were you know
they're busting each other's chops like
it was him and Cameron champ who's new
on the tour and who's like just crushing
it I think he's gone there's one drive
of 430 yards his hand Boyd Summerhays so
Zach Johnson who's of course great
player of course yeah so are you saying
Michael Pena are you giving strokes to
the course when you no no no you're not
plumb like I'm like a no I'm not like a
5 handicap it's hard to be like a good
guy man plus I'm a Hollywood 5
which means did you just say the words
only yeah I mean come on look me in the
face well no I got buddies like Scott
would for instance you know he's like
they're all like and Oliver Hudson
they're all scratch or plus the actor
Oliver Hudson Oliver Hudson is oh he's a
stick man he can really really play yeah
okay so you're fought you're only
5-under but we don't know I'm like I'm
gonna five handicap means like I you
know like okay so your father handicap
so you're only fob so when you're
playing with these guys these
professionals I mean can you hang with
them they flip you some strokes and you
have a little bit see but I played like
two weeks ago I played with Tommy I
murder the third you know he's on the
Champions Tour ca3 yeah I shot the best
round you know that I that I have in a
while like it was over he shot an easy
65 like 7-under like five six seven
under you something isn't it amazing the
difference are when you're at that level
is is is the putter
I totally it is that it is but it also
you know for guys like me it's also the
the you know the driver and like
everything else because they they're
just so consistent they drive it down
the fairway no it's amazing and throwing
darts you know I remember when I when I
was on SportsCenter years ago and the
Greater Hartford open was played gho as
it was known at the time the TPC and
Cromwell Connecticut right so we would
be standing there on the 17th fairway
just me and my buddies just watching
everybody drive it to the same spot you
could see there was like a blazing there
was like a 20 square foot area where
there were all these divots of everybody
hitting the approach shot for this is
pretty much the same spot yeah and then
the question was how close could they
throw the dart to the hole over the
water and who would be the one close
enough to just make a distal part and
that was the difference as to who did
well on the 17th hole er yeah exactly
and what's what's funny especially about
live professional golf is that it's it
seems like they just press the start
button like this machine just propels
the golf ball and they don't swing they
don't swing as hard it doesn't look as
awkward and as hard as like some
amateurs when they're trying to swing
out of their socks and it just goes like
you say and one
spot they're normally grouped up in
threes and then whoever putts the best
you know like a 65 doesn't look that
different from the 72 Michael Pena here
on the Rich Eisen show what is this
general sense of the guys that you hang
out with her talk you know if the name
names whatever about the thoughts on on
tiger and his resurgence Tiger well I
was talking to my friend Obama and go on
and he's a big fan of Tigers I won't say
his last name no I'm not friends with
Obama there's the comic timing if
somebody who's an actor who does both
money and drama
okay very good sorry continue on no but
it's amazing because I'm like I just
started to break it down for myself and
anybody who was like you know in college
or like 25 grew up with Tiger and that's
them in their heyday mm-hmm you know and
now they probably have dad bonds you
know so like they're rooting for the old
man you know and instead of hanging out
in a bar with their buddies is with
their family and they're probably making
too much noise like you know like shut
up
Perry and you know they they got the dad
bods would probably crack open a beer or
something and so seeing that guy win is
amazing I think it would be one of the
biggest comebacks of all time if that
guy actually eclipses Jack Nicklaus his
majors right majors records of 18
records he's got 14 now yes I think it'd
be amazing if he won one especially with
the competition nowadays the golfers are
way different you got Rickie Fowler
Dustin Johnson Brooks koepka those guys
that are they're like real athletes like
in the eighties they didn't really look
like like major you know athletes like
multiple or dad so are you saying
Michael Payne you
narcos Mexico again available for
streaming this Friday on Netflix and
we'll get there in a second like are you
saying Michael Pena that for all of
those of a certain age right rooting for
Tiger right now right to cap his
resurgence it is nothing to do with
Tiger but everything to do with a
psychological avoidance of a midlife
crisis yeah I mean I
so you're saying I would take the
average body fat percentage and think
that it's probably around 20 most tiger
fans Ricky Fowler fans clicking the
teens okay who's got the leanest body
fat of anybody uh of a fan base right
now I I'm gonna say obviously all of
them the Ricky Fowler cuz there's a lot
of kids that might have - body fat I
don't know like my son okay those guys
dressing up in all orange they you know
they don't know tiger and I asked with
hesitancy what about the Phil Mickelson
fan base dude he has a he has a dad bod
right now and he's on tour I think IG I
think John Daly probably has he's on the
other so Daly's on one extreme he's on
the extreme Tigers Tigers like all the
all that 40-somethings and irshaf Lee's
on another on the other extreme or some
welly xander softly he he's not Dodd bet
dad bod no he's kid bog he's kids on
yeah although the young guys you know
the guys they're all they're all in
their 20s now before we get to uh
talking about your your your new show
narcos mexico you want you need some
help you told me backstage that you need
some help fantasy football yes fantasy
football it's like I can't even imagine
what your job is like like you know
there's a there's a couple the shows
that are just entirely for fantasy that
is true um you know Le'Veon Bell I like
a lot of guys picked him first you did
take living on them no I didn't I got
you know this was the first time they
otter drafted
um because I just wasn't able to too
busy you're busy man yeah I was in a
plane like I guess sir that was in two
mu by Mumbai I by Mumbai than Dubai than
here okay yeah Wow
it's like 20 hours of flying damn yeah
so of course you're Auto picking yeah
I'm otter picking I'm also what what's
your current predicament so here's the
thing I'm like I I picked up taking your
phone away every walk what's the name
your team first it's the only thing that
keeps me close to America yes okay so
what what I got Ryan's Fitzpatrick I got
fits magic you got fits magic I got
Ezekiel Elliott okay okay I got Richard
and running back but I got Michael
Thomas from New Orleans
guy catches it so he's great my god Mike
Evans and then I got Zach Ertz a tight
end he's actually crushing he's killing
it right now uh-huh
this is an auto draft this is an order
draft but these are guys I know but you
picked up Ryan Fitzpatrick though right
I picked up Ryan Fitzpatrick I picked up
Richard I picked up pootie or cutie I
don't know how you call it yeah right I
did have fuller before he got her who's
off the waiver wire as well and then you
know defense but I think what's your
what's your team name Apache butter
knife a patch okay because it sounds
tough but it's not Apache butter knives
well if you have a butter knife you're
not doing much damage to patching except
a piece of butter okay
understood yeah okay and what's your
team record right now it's five and four
right now I started off at five and one
what do you what do you need what can I
help you with I don't know like who do
you think is gonna be who's on the
waiver wire I don't know I picked up
Amendola Watts from the tight end oh
yeah yeah Brandon Marshall doesn't seem
to be doing I wouldn't touch him right
now not yet yeah I don't know whatever
the secret is the fantasy for Vaughn
don't have it how many teams are there
in your league ah ten TJ I'm in a year
ten TJ Jefferson a guy you reaching out
to it as well like look here's what
we'll do is when when we're done here
I'll take a look at your way to wire and
I don't see what I got yeah for you okay
we have a friend Travis case he helps me
out and he's got horrible advice and
he's number one in your league that's
the way it works man these guys are I
swear it's all luck
it really is unless it's the residue of
design right Chris our team is
unstoppable we're not if we're the touch
of the Vermeil is nine and one in the
Allison changed celebrity fantasy
football Allison chains yeah we're
taking down Duff McKagan
and go for an even ten wins yes sir
oh wow that was my first concert ever is
that right Wow
oh man dude I went to like I grew up in
like like kind of the Poirier in Chicago
huh and then I went to this prep school
Marist high school and it was like it
was a culture shock and they invited me
to well they said I should definitely go
to this concert and it was Lollapalooza
and it was I was I couldn't it was
unbelievable
thing do you want to be in there who
actually knew the words to these songs
do you want to be in their league next
year oh that would be awesome
are you kidding me we can here's what
will make happen you you can be in the
Alice in Chains League next year for two
reasons one is because I want to make
your you happy you came from Mumbai to
Dubai to the Rich Eisen show so I
greatly appreciate this and two is your
sucker who auto-drive come on they took
you know they took Le'Veon Bell oh yeah
those a big who would have guessed that
that guy's out come how do you think
that's gonna hurt him like what happened
to Dez Bryant like he you know he sat
out for the majority but I think look
kilise pops on people who practice every
week and Achilles pop on people who
haven't played in a while and levy on
bail that is gonna be a fascinating
conversation of what happens when he
hits free agency and what he's gonna
look like next year it's a conversation
that's gonna die down now but pop up
again once the season's over and be
dominant for 2019 it seemed you think
he's gonna be dominant like what no I
think the storyline will be dominant he
will be I think he's gonna be very good
he's or terrific he's 26 years 27 like
if he was 30 31 32 like you got to keep
the body going
where's earning ears are still there
just like you so narcos mexico is a
completely new series so anybody who
thinks this is an extension of the famed
narcos yeah on Netflix would be wrong
right because it started off in Columbia
and now it's Oh Columbia and then now
it's in now it's in Mexico and it's a
whole new cast and it's great I mean
it's it's still the same narcos but you
know what I'm really excited for its
people to check out these like these
Mexican actors they got the best of the
best in Mexico
Joaquin co-ceo I don't know like if
you're okay with reading subtitles like
I think he just knocks it out it that's
great yeah I I I'm not subtitle averse
yes because you said subtitles doesn't
mean it's not good yeah I can work you
know what I mean yeah you can work or
entertain exactly I can
there and have to be worked exactly why
did you choose to do this Michael well
because well first of all is because it
was it was in a completely different
area it's a brand new start and I
thought it was kind of exciting to start
this off to establish this season in
Mexico which I think hopefully they can
go 2 or 3 in Mexico but the characters
Kiki Camarena mmm and he was you know
he's in the cover of Time magazine
real life yeah in real life yeah he was
and he's a Latin American Hero and you
could start streaming it again this
Friday oh yeah once again not Nick's not
a continuation pretty much like every
drive in the NBA not a continuation at
all thanks for coming on Mike yeah
absolutely
you and what we will definitely hook you
up with the Allison change people oh
there that would be awesome yeah we got
Garland in the league this year we can
get Michael Payne yeah what's your
what's your record by the way what we're
not and why nine to eleven excuse me
destroying it oh yeah we love ya we're
901 yeah mm-hmm we're not a one who's
your kid can I just quickly who's your
squad our court arc mo the drafted you
drafted Matt - Matt Ryan and Carson
Wentz and I picked up Jared Goff because
nobody drafted then you'd been crushing
by the cream hunt Michael Thomas Adam
Thielen you got Michael Thomas and Adam
feeling happy yeah Minnesota we're
hooked on a feeling so yeah we are other
running backs are either carry on
Johnson or og pick him up from the shark
oi have to carry I picked up Nick Chubb
midseason so he's the general manager
anomaly on the day I'm the the
day-to-day week-to-week guy together
combination wise the touch of the
Vermeil is gonna make everybody cry
everybody's crying and I don't see James
Lee I just hope that we get any final
without with Jerry Cantrell so we can
run back the truck he comes here and and
we make a bet we were in the Superbowl
to get you together two years ago oh
well so if I lost I had a dress like a
glam punk rocker I want to see the
picture it's in the hallway as you can
race you can walk out sorry that's
assuming that you lost I did lose okay I
did lose and he brought it there I'm
right there I'm in I'm in luck
Steel's gear from he could be just about
anybody there that's me but if he lost
and he refuses to take this bed up again
which is too damn bad because we are
nominating right now okay
he would have to come on this show and
sing an acoustic version of let it go
from frozen Oh which he just won't do he
doesn't I can coach him a little bit
it's it's needs to hear Jerry Cantrell
talk about how the cold doesn't bother
him anyway
it's gotta happen yeah and the touch of
the Vermeil is what's gonna make it
happen ion huh
crushing it a Duke that's true Wow look
could you drop a knowledge going out the
door well no I just you know cuz I'm
watching photographs behind you I just
watched a nob I just yeah I'm watching
photographs but I watch a lot of like
YouTube like an all these kids like
mellow for instance you know Zoe's
brother and it's it's really great to
see like how to videos of lamella ball
yeah when it was it was a three brothers
I know they were crushing everyone in
high school I'm very well aware of that
yeah exactly
you should strike me as a man who's so
busy but you're spending tunnelled you
too nobody's nobody's too busy for
YouTube by the way that's a great that's
a way that's words to live by we all do
the same thing when we're you know go to
the bathroom we're scroll on Instagram
people know when they're on Twitter
because you're like it must be in the
restroom because it's a lot of action
action by the way that is the the first
album of the new band Gruden in the tank
job is scrolling Instagram likes good to
see you Michael Pat real Michael Pena on
Twitter check out narcos Mexico on
Netflix starting to stream this Friday
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience